tears are for one two things a sadness
the Apache say that is too hard to
understand or a love that is real Duane
dog Chapman opens up to ETS Kevin
Frazier in his first sit-down interview
since losing his beloved wife Beth
Chapman how you doing in a new
experience that you have you don't know
how you're doing because you've never
experienced it I have a lot of people
that depend on me all my supervisors
said dog it's time to man up so I'm
trying to mana is there such thing as
man enough in a situation like this
you're asking me that yes and you know
there is you I am a crybaby
I am I blame it on my heritage mm-hmm I
can cry talking about crying so I will
would be crying through the whole thing
and I saw I can't stop it so I can't do
that and decisions I can't make them
right now I just might lost my wife you
can't do that you can't use this as an
excuse okay hmm
so Manning up would be you know not get
over it but face it take over it what's
in that pink box well I've never done
ashes of my life and that's what she
wanted and then she wants me to do it
and put the same thing just put on a
fireplace or something so yeah this is
the most more of it stuff brah oh it's
like it's like morbid right what were
her final wishes what if she want you to
do with those ashes
well she said scatter some leave some on
the fireplace of course when I go to
heaven she wants me in the box with her
not like will I like you know I was
gonna do all the scattering I did you
know blah blah blah and then I looked at
it thought I'm not gonna throw you
Kawai I just throw away it start over I
can't do that so right now I like him
it can't be more of it I don't you know
I haven't gotten past the place where
I'm still putting a pillow where she was
and covering it up like the jailhouse
escape hmm right I mean it and then I
wake up bill likes ear and it doesn't
register in any juror I'm still there
I've lost 17 pounds cheering ice helps
okay
and I lost 17 pounds in about two weeks
I need to bulk up again but I can't even
I can't eat I do buy some full you know
there's a lot of so I got to force feed
myself like I force-fed earth could keep
going to keep going yep well and I'm not
suicidal please my god no I would never
commit suicide none of that crap but I
am ready now to go so you're saying if
you have to go you're ready yes
absolutely
Beth was never ready there's five or
seven things right
denial making a deal blaming someone and
the doctor told me and the final one is
acceptance
I said well brah that there's property
of dog she's never gonna get to
acceptance she never did
she never accepted it she wasn't ready
nope